the fantasy cast lists have been posted
wow so I guess on receiver one on the
first team oh I'm gonna break some legs
CMC is the lead on the third best team
but what if he get hurt that's how you
all sound a freshman got a better part
than me wow can't wait to see my name in
lights be Jean Robinson say mister you
know where I could find the big time
listen kid they call it fantasy for a
reason
foreign
[Music]
understudy don't be mad but I gotta Miss
like the first couple of shows young
back someone got cast ahead of us
because they're cheap JT it's not fair
he's on vocal rest uh receivers how now
AJ brown cows
you're a high upside receiver too
congrats but I mean not bet let's see
hey there I am I barely even auditioned
maybe I should transfer got no show this
is by the guy who always drafts a QB too
early
and my supporter cast is two kickers can
they catch this show was cast by someone
who hasn't been following football in a
few years yes and this last one is
selected by someone who thinks they are
fantasy jeans who's Sam laportem you are
oh time for the first rehearsal hope
everyone's patient with me
uh Line This is why you come to
rehearsal should have picked me
ew Thrills due to a killer script and
natural Talent
players refused to perform Jordan love
puts on a show for Chicago fans
and holy the giants look rough